the highly anticipated Tesla cyber truck
has just made another public appearance
this time it's a picture shared by
Twitter user Hall Mars catalog the Cyber
truck seems to be covered in Grime and
various sensors suggesting that Tesla
has been putting it through some
rigorous testing so today let's analyze
this new Cybertron prototype and see
what this picture might tell us about
the final production cyber truck along
with some new updates shared by Tesla
the Cyber Truck Body and sensors Elon
announced earlier this year that the
Cyber truck is scheduled for delivery in
2023 so this picture lets us Tesla fans
know that they are working hard to
Perfect the final sensors and Camera
alignments before production begins
which is an encouraging sign the most
notable thing in this picture was the
new Cyber truck side mirrors Yes you
heard that right side mirrors remember
when Tesla unveiled a cyber truck
without mirrors and I told you that they
wouldn't be able to roll out that design
in the US just yet because of safety
policies that require vehicles to have
side mirrors well well this update to
the body tells us one thing Tesla will
not be waiting for policy change to
release the Cyber truck to their U.S
market instead they will have mirrors as
required that doesn't mean that Tesla's
use of cameras in their vehicles is a
thing of the past because this cyber
truck seems to have big sensors and
cameras all over it with that said there
is speculation that the setup is being
used to calibrate the autopilot so the
external sensor Suite is there to
confirm that visual data matches radar
data another speculation is that the
team at Tesla is trying to figure out
where to place the cameras that the
Cyber truck will have more calibration
has been done on the wheels with a bulgy
ring around the center lug nuts called
The Wheel Force transducer well it's
more than likely that this is the final
cyber Truck Body because it wouldn't
make a lot of sense for all this to be
done only to turn around and make
changes that will take them a few steps
back especially now that they are past
their intended launch date with all that
data put together we may be looking at
fully automated Vehicles soon think of
what you will do with all that free time
when you no longer have to draw Drive
having said that we know Tesla is not
one to blend in with the crowd and the
manufacturers always go the extra mile
to ensure the vehicles are an instant
hit among the eager fan base one aspect
where the Cyber truck stands out from
other automated electric vehicles on the
market is its exceptional features such
as the integration of an internet
connection within the truck no matter
where you drive it yep that's right you
can take it into the Wilderness without
worrying about losing connection with
the rest of the world doesn't that sound
futuristic let's see what the hype is
about internet connection inside the
truck the new cybertruck prototype
features a limited starlink internet
connection as soon as SpaceX deploys
their second generation of communication
satellites that doesn't sound like a
whole lot of internet at first but it's
not a bad deal when you consider that
this service is mostly reserved for use
in the wilderness it is highly unlikely
that there will be crowds trying to use
the limited connection compounding the
problem so although you can't Vlog or
even stream your favorite shows this
connection is enough to send out a text
message message and to have a voice call
which is all you need to alert people of
emergency situations and maybe the
difference between life and death the
internet connection update was announced
after SpaceX and T-Mobile's partnership
announcement which will see updated
starlink satellites connecting directly
with mobile phones so the internet
connection by starlink will be from a
portion of Tesla's already existing 5G
Network spectrum that enables them to
provide limited service to most areas in
the US even though the T-Mobile press
release did not specifically list the
areas they will cover they mentioned
that this new service would provide
coverage in areas that have not been
reachable by traditional mobile signals
even so some people wonder whether the
limited bandwidth may just be enough to
operate the Tesla navigation system so
it's accessible in remote areas this
would be another smart move for Tesla to
set itself apart from the other
automobile manufacturers it would be
even better for the Cyber truck because
it is the perfect vehicle to get lost in
the wilderness for a start the Emergency
Services connection is enough but I
can't help being excited about future at
the rate things are developing it looks
like Tesla will end up integrating the
Cyber truck fully with starlink features
so now that we know the Cyber truck
boasts remarkable sensors cameras and
internet connectivity what else do the
fans have to look forward to let's take
a glance at the interior design of the
truck and see what the manufacturers
have to offer the windshield wiper and
the interior changes through the
Prototype of all the things Tesla fans
and critics could choose to focus on the
wiper blade on the truck gets the most
attention Okay okay maybe not the most
but definitely more compared to other
vehicles at the Michigan International
Speedway earlier this year the absence
of a windshield wiper was one of the
features that stood out about the Cyber
truck the vehicle has been famous for
changes in the design of its windshield
wiper over the years so the complete
absence of one Drew particular attention
cybertruck started with no wiper at all
and then went on to feature a
ridiculously oversized wiper followed by
an undersized one and now we've come
full circle with the latest prototype
featuring no windshield wiper all over
again we've also been pretty lucky with
glimpses of the interior of the Cyber
truck and you can notice how the design
has undergone several changes with the
latest prototype looking considerably
different from the version we initially
saw originally the Cyber truck interior
looked like it would have a plain model
3 style dashboard made out of marble
later Tesla revealed that it was
actually recycled paper composited
together to give the appearance of
marble now even though that's super cool
the latest version features a more Model
S interior with sharper angles appearing
much different from the Prototype Tesla
first disclosed there's also an
instrument cluster in front of the
driver unlike what was present on the
original build and you also get Tesla's
plaid steering yoke thing featuring a
big hole where the airbag should be
along with wires protruding out one of
the most distinctive changes from the
initial cybertruck prototypes is perhaps
the upgraded middle section in the front
row we saw that the original build
featured a middle seat similar to what
most pickup trucks used to have but now
the Cyber truck has taken a fresh
perspective and installed a giant wonky
console looking seat that can be folded
up serving the same purpose but with a
much cooler Outlook there's also plenty
of space safe for legroom in the middle
so that's great news for many of you
that's the inward appearance of the
Cyber truck but its external features
don't fall short either next up I'll
show you guys what Tesla has in store
for us with regards to the cybertruck's
battery motor and other technical
specifications battery motor and other
specs although Tesla's old Fremont
Factory is one of its least efficient
plants especially compared to its
gigafactory in Berlin and the new one in
Austin it shouldn't be underestimated by
any means it's the only one that
produces all four EV models that Tesla
currently sells and most importantly it
has a remarkable battery manufacturing
facility as well with respect to the
Cyber truck that is to be released next
year the Fremont Factory is particularly
relevant because this is the place where
Tesla's new and revolutionary 4680 cells
are made you know the one set to be
featured in The much-awaited Cyber truck
I can't say for sure if the 4680
batteries are as revolutionary as Tesla
presented them to be but they do promise
drastic cost savings from their usage
primarily because the design of the
battery Stacks multiple cells in one
housing rather than dry electrode
manufacturing another super cool aspect
of the Cyber truck that I absolutely
cannot ignore is its motor Elon
confirmed that he plans on updating the
Cyber truck with a full motor
configuration that will enable
independent power at each wheel with
ultra Fast Response torque and
four-wheel steering with a tank or a
crab mode like the Hummer EV this would
be a tremendous improvement from the
tri-motor version with over 500 miles of
range that was first unveiled in 2019.
it's pretty clear by now that Tesla has
a lot going on with much more planned
than most of us anticipate the Cyber
truck is ready to be finally released in
2023 after its initial debut in 2019 and
although there has been a huge delay in
its final production it wouldn't be true
to say that fans have lost interest or
excitement in fact a significant
proportion of Tesla enthusia enthusiasts
have already pre-ordered the Cyber truck
and I'm sure they won't regret their
decision when the incredible vehicle
finally hits the market so what do you
think of Tesla's new Cyber truck update
what about all the other developments in
the pipeline let me know what you think
in the comment section below if you
enjoyed this video hit the Subscribe
button and continue watching the next
video by clicking on one of the cards on
your screen thank you for watching and
I'll see you next time